روسيا تتهم وامريكا بالسيعي الاختيار
عائله اللاعب المغربي بوفالت في نبا وفاه
والدته الحكومه البرازيليه تحاضرنشا ذهبيا
الاسطوره لهذا الاخبار وغيرها تنقلها لكم
من قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
تبدا من روسيا حيث قال وزير الخارج
بتوجيه ضربه قطع كامله
انه اذا فكر شخص ما في هذا الامر فعليه ان
يفكر بشكل افضل في العواقب المحتمله لهذا
النوع من الخطاب
بعد ما خطفت والدته لاعب المغربي سفيان
بوفال الانظار في كاس العالم تحدثت حسابات
على مواقع التواصل عن وفاتها في مدينه
تازه المغربيه خلال الساعات الاخيره
من اشقاء اللاعب بوفال عبره حسابهم في
انستغرام وذلك عن طريق صوره كتب فيها
الحمد لله انها بخير وشكرا لرسائل لكم
مع ابنها عندما نزلت لارض الملعب واحتفلت
معها بيت تاهل المنتخب الى المربع الذهبي
لاول مره في تاريخه
في حادثه الماساويه وقعت بمصر اقدم مدرس
على انهاء حياته بتناول قرصان في بث مباشر
عبر حسابه على موقع فيسبوك بسببي ازمه
النفسيه تعرض لها المدرس انها حياته في
غرفه بمنزله في محافظه الفيوم كشفا عن
وجود خلافات مع سيده لم يذكر اسم كانت
السبب في تخلصهم من حياته لما تحدث
التقارير انا المدرس اصيب بحاله ارشاديه
نقل لمعهد السموم لكنه توفي متاثرا
باصابته التي تبين حدوثها جرى تناوله لقرص
مبيد حشريا
الى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه المره
ارتفعت حصلت العاصفه الثلجيه القاسيه التي
تضرب البلاد الى 50 قتيلا على الاقل في
اثنتي عشر ولايه بما صدق بعض على اعلان
الطوارئ لتقديم الدعم لولايه اكثر تضارا
من العاصفه دائره الارصاد الجويه ذكرت ان
60% من سكان الولايات المتحده تلقوا
تحذيرات متعلقه بالعاصفه فيما تحدث
التقارير عن وجود خسائر فادحه في نيويورك
على الاخص حيث نقيه 25 شخصا خدفه كما
اشارت مواقع مختصه الى ان مجموعه الرحلات
منذ بدايه العاصفه تجاوز 15,000 رحله
ما في خبرنا الاخير كشفت صحف برازيليه انا
الحكومه تناسق مع الاتحاد المحلي لكره
القدم ونادي سانتوس للاستعداد للساعات
التي تلي الاعلان عن وفاه الاسطوره تقارير
افادت بان نادي سانتوس اقام خيمه ضخمه في
ملعبه استعدادا لجنازه اللاعب الاسطوره
بالاضافه الى نعشق ذهبي وضعت عليه الكثير
من الصور لاسطوره كره القدم البرازيليه
لما تحدثت
بالغ من العمر 82 عاما يخسروا ببطء معركه
ضد السرطان تقول عائلته ان حال
[موسيقى]